hi everyone thanks sober my name is Greg
I'm part in development manager at
Google Play and I lead a lot of our VR
focused the RNA are focused efforts in
Europe so this talk will be so
philosophical a little bit a little bit
practical and the idea is to give you a
taste of our vision for what we now call
immersive computing which we see now
emerging through the frameworks of AR
and VR and perhaps most importantly give
you a little bit of inspiration and a
way of thinking around this topic and
what this might mean for you as a
developer then explain some of the tools
that we have in place today to help you
succeed in this area so let's start with
the vision so ultimately this comes down
to making technology work a lot more
like we do and does anyone know roughly
what year this photos from no 40s so
that's so it's a computer punch card
from the 40s and so that's obviously not
the most frictionless and intuitive way
of interacting with the computer I think
you're all agree with that and so I
think it's fair to say that smartphones
were truly the first breakthrough in
terms of have innovation and interfaces
and accessibility with computers and
what they can do and still the level of
abstraction remains right so when you
call a friend on your phone you don't
really see them like you see them in
real life you see this flat lifeless
version of them on the screen and
equally when you're looking for a
restaurant your phone doesn't really
walk you to the restaurant you still
have to look at your phone and see this
blue dots and then find a way of
navigating there it's not ideal it's
getting better but it's not ideal so
with the massive computing we're saying
that instead of staring at our screens
and constantly checking our phones we'll
be able to interact with the world and
computers
more natural way we'll be able to hold
up our heads to the real and virtual
worlds around us okay that's kind of the
high-level philosophy as to how we think
about this so what is the immersive
computing so the way we think of this is
really as a spectrum with a R and D are
as two points on it so on the very right
you have virtual reality which is fully
computer-generated and the very left you
have reality or you can call it a real
reality as what we're taking part in
right here and in the middle the sort of
the middle part is augmented reality and
this layer of computer-generated reality
that comes on top of our real world
another way to put it is virtual reality
can take you anywhere as this beautiful
image shows and augmented reality can
bring anything to you so this is all
kind of intuitive so let's take a look
at some of the efforts and the latest
things that we've done in the augmented
reality space so if you think back 10
years ago that was one of the first
Android devices computers so computers
as phones have become a lot more
powerful and sort of interesting in
terms of what they can do yet their
understanding contextual understanding
of the world around them has become
pretty limited with AR this equation
will be changed dramatically
this will really bring the next big
shift in terms of computers
understanding the world around them in a
completely different way so at the most
basic fundamental level this is about
providing timely and relevant digital
information in the context of the real
world so here you've got an example of
da Vinci's lady with the ermine where
the very first version of the painting
didn't even have
and then you can see the progression to
the very final version where actually
the face of the lady has changed
dramatically and that's a really rich
and interesting digital contextual
information that you just wouldn't have
access to in the same way without this
AR technology so what are some of the
other use cases well shopping is a
really obvious and fun one and kind of
immediately practically useful where you
can essentially overlay any digital
object into a physical space and see
what this is gonna look like you can
learn about real-life objects in a
completely new and interactive way which
is kind of shown by this high-end coffee
machine where you can kind of learn and
interact in this way so games is
obviously a huge use case and you know
as we all know Pokemon Go has really
planted the seed in this space and we
are only going to see more and more
amazing stuff coming in terms of gaming
and AR and last but not least the
example that I use the aliens of the
navigation it becomes this contextual
window into the world where instead of
holding down your phone and figuring out
how to relate to it how to relate to
your external world with an external
object you'll actually be using the
phone as a window and be able to see
contextual information around you and
navigational prompts in a much more
intuitive way so at Google as a lot of
you know we started our a our efforts
with tango in 2014 now tango was a
hardware play as intrinsically
everything Hardware it's a lot harder to
scale and distribute so two months ago
we've announced air core which is all
about AR at the scale of Android so
let's take a quick look at what this can
do so motion tracking this is a really
fundamental aspect of AR so it knows
where your phone is in space secondly
environmental understanding so is in
this case it knows that a table is
indeed a table and then you can place
objects on it the same goes for walls
and ceilings
Lyde estimations super important too so
that is in this example the object knows
when the light in the room is switched
off and it can adjust accordingly
right now this is running on pixel
devices in Samsung as a with more OMS
coming on board very quickly and we're
expecting over 100 million devices very
soon the way we think of this is really
as both a feature and a foundation
meaning that we certainly hope that you
are able to integrate air core and error
experiences within your existing apps
and we hope that this will give kind of
birth to whole new types of experiences
that are natively AR let's take a look
at some of this in action now play the
video
[Music]
[Applause]
amazing so that's for AR and let's move
on to VR now and see what we've done
there in the last couple of months or so
so last year in November we've launched
daydream which is all about basically
high-end premium VR experiences at the
scale of Android interactive experiences
and comfortable headsets then this year
we've announced with more devices that
are supporting daydream so that you can
use they dream on almost any high-end
Android device most notably Samsung S
eight is now supporting daydream as well
and we're expecting even more IMS to
come on board in the next year or so in
terms of software and hardware and by
the way the new Google daydream view
with more colors and even more comfort
in terms of software we have even more
ABS than before so the momentum is quite
strong
you know let's keep in mind that
developing for VR and let's be honest
about this is still very hard and quite
expensive so we're trying to be very
careful as to how we bring this to
market
having said that all Android develop is
now able to develop for VR and we're
seeing a lot more organic titles coming
to the store which were supporting
through featuring in terms of the
product itself and what daydream looks
like inside we've made it even easier to
discover interact with and share
experiences in VR so let's take a look
at what this means in terms of discovery
daydream home has an updated look with
these new tabs at the top which makes it
even easier to engage users and keep
users in VR for longer therefore kind of
developing this daily use of VR which we
think is so so important by taking it
sort of mainstream dashboard is
extremely powerful as well so this
enables you to interact with your
Android notifications without having to
take off the headset casting that was
one of the most acts for us for teachers
so the power of chromecast and daydream
now enables you to stream
or cast your dr experience in the
headset on to any large screen therefore
making the experience a lot more social
screenshot and video capture is also
here so that you can now share your
experiences on all the usual channels
making it more accessible for users to
see what you're actually up to in your
VR environment
last but not least and this is a really
cool one YouTube Co watching so you can
actually experience YouTube on daydream
concurrently with your friends so we've
talked a lot about the philosophy what
we've done with AR and VR on the product
side and I want to leave you with a kind
of a taste of the future so this
convergence of a R and D are those two
points in the spectrum is pretty
inevitable and we think this will enable
a new type of devices to come to the
market first one such device is the
Lenovo all-in-one headset that will come
to the market early next year this will
use part of the AR technology such as
motion tracking and depth perception and
will be obviously running daydream so
you can interact with your VR
experiences in a more richer and kind of
untethered way with more functionality
and more freedom to move so beyond that
we've all heard the term mixed reality
and so let's see what shape that takes
most likely in form of devices that will
combine both AR and ER in one and so
immersive computing and its future and
present frankly is pretty exciting and
we're only just at the very beginning
you